hello friends
i'm happy to see all of you here today
this is actually exactly what i say to
the people who visit us
at the la crosse public library and i
say it because i mean it
the children who come into our library
are my friends and that i care about
their needs and their futures
i want them to be happy and successful i
hope that they'll find great books
or a movie that delights them or the
solution to a tricky problem
libraries in general have this wonderful
reputation of really caring about our
communities
we put out mission statements and
statements of purpose that say that
we connect our community to the broader
world
we engage minds we create lifelong
learners
and these ideals are really important to
us as libraries because
we know the power they have to create a
better world
a more connected world a more engaged
and empathetic world
books have power information has power
and for the powerless in our communities
being able to connect to that is even
more important
in 1995 betty hart and todd risley
published a study that found that
working class families and those being
served by welfare
experience what we now refer to as the
30 million word gap
essentially what they learned is that
children in these families are hearing
so many fewer words each day that by the
time they are three years old
there's this enormous disparity in their
learned language
and that gap in words follows them as
they enter school and it results in
later reading poorer reading skills a
lack of success overall
children need to hear words every day
and they need to hear not just
our day-to-day conversation they have to
hear rare words
those outside the common lexicon we
share of around ten thousand
i'm going to read you a short snippet
from a children's book
by one of our favorite authors in the
children's room eric carl
some of you might know his work the very
hungry caterpillar
but this is from slowly slowly slowly
said the sloth
finally the sloth replied it is true
that i am slow
quiet and boring i am lackadaisical
i dawdle and i dilly dally i am also
unflappable
languid stoic impassive sluggish
lethargic placid calm
mellow laid back and well flawful
i am relaxed and tranquil and i like to
live in peace
but i'm not lazy then the sloth yawned
and said that's just how i am i like to
do things
slowly slowly slowly
so you can see from this very brief
example from one book
in our library how eric carl used 20
different words to get the same idea
across to children
now we know that a lot of the families
visiting us at the library
a lot of our friends are struggling
financially
we know that some of them are living in
poverty and don't have enough to eat or
anywhere safe to live
we know that our friend james who comes
in after school and is staying at a
local shelter isn't reading at grade
level and has probably never read at
grade level
we know we have that 30 million word gap
and a corresponding achievement gap by
the time kids enter the third grade
both of which directly correlate to
income level
so what's the responsibility of
libraries in addressing these gaps how
can we help our friends be more
successful
more educated and someday better global
citizens
it starts with ensuring free and
equitable access
to everything libraries offer them books
level the playing field
by exposing children of every
socioeconomic background
to words at the library we provide
programs that are based on the five
tenets of early literacy
playing singing talking reading and
writing
we offer programs for adults on computer
classes and job skills training
business startups we do all this great
work
for our community members and at the
same time we counteract it
by charging fines and fees of our
patrons
today in lacrosse 10 000 of our users
are unable to check out library
materials because of fines and fees
if we narrow in on our neighborhoods
experiencing the most poverty those
where 82 percent of the student body is
considered economically disadvantaged
the number rises to 23 percent of the
neighborhood and these are local numbers
it's true but they hold
true nationwide in libraries across the
country that charge fines
the poorest neighborhoods have the most
number of people blocked from use
in fact the colorado state library was
so worried about this they published a
white paper
and they stated unequivocally that it's
the fear of fines
that keeps poor families out of
libraries
a colleague of mine took a ride in a
lift in atlanta last year
and he started chatting with his driver
about libraries as we do
and she told him she grew up visiting
her local library she loved it
but now that she's a parent with three
children of her own there's no way she
would allow them to get a library card
because of the strict deadlines
libraries impose
she said it would be like another credit
card that i can't pay
meanwhile when other libraries have
experimented
with eliminating fines like one in san
rafael
that took away children's fines they had
126 percent
increase in child card applications
within the first few months
when people aren't afraid of the fines
they might accrue they line up
to access what we have to offer
so what are we telling people then we
have these two disparate ideas
on the one hand we're champions of
democracy
and we claim that we are there so that
every citizen
can educate themselves we're advocates
for the power early literacy has to
reduce that achievement gap
and eliminate the word cap we tell
people we're here to help you
on the other hand if you're struggling
financially
and you make a mistake the kind of
mistake that anyone in this room could
make
your tote bag that belongs to the
library sits by your back door
for a couple of weeks longer than it
should
you lose a cd you spill your coffee on a
book
suddenly we're not here for you so much
anymore because if that happens
we're going to make you pay for it and
if you can't pay for it
you're out of luck i have been a
librarian for a lot of years and in the
past few years
i myself have paid over 500 in league
fines
now you might wonder why i mean i'm
there every day and i certainly know how
the system works
but like all of our friends at the
library
i am busy i lose track of things
my house is sometimes messy and i
have lost a dvd or two under the sofa
and i have been fortunate enough to be
able to pay
that 500 over the last several years if
not happily
at least had the means to do it so is
that fair and equitable service
if some of us can pay our fines
and continue to operate as we always
have and others of us
make one mistake and no longer are
welcome back
it's simply not
now why would we continue to operate
under a model that hurts
our most vulnerable patrons the most
there are reasons
there are reasons like responsibility
there are some libraries that really
feel that it's our job to teach people
responsibility
and they haven't figured out that there
might be ways to do that that don't
equate to dollars
there's also this idea that we share the
resources collectively in a community
and so we have to take turns
if i keep my my little pony movie for
too long
and somebody else wants to watch it it's
not fair
and then there's the money community
members
often love their libraries and they
don't want us
to not be able to sustain the services
we offer
luckily we can address all of these
things in a variety of ways
without scaring away our most vulnerable
populations
some libraries have gone to a netflix
model
you might be familiar with this you
check things out
when you're done with them you return
them
if you don't return them you can't check
more things out
but once you do it's all forgiven it's
fine
you can check out again others continue
to charge fines but they want to offer
alternatives to their library
patrons and so they do things like food
for fines where you bring in canned
goods
or read away your fines where you can
read off your fines
there's even another library in
wisconsin that offers scratch-off
tickets at their counter so you can
scratch off and get 10
off or 20 off your fines that day
and there are amnesty days one day a
year you bring back your late materials
and all is forgiven there was a library
in san francisco that did an amnesty day
last year
and they welcomed back five thousand
users who had been blocked
that same day they received more than
seven hundred
items that were overdue among them was
one book that was 100 years overdue
so i know that sounds ridiculous but i
experienced that people will stay away
from the library rather than face the
authority of the librarian when they
have late items
as michael might have mentioned i've
been a librarian for 15 years and my mom
hasn't been in a library in decades
because when she was young she lost a
book
so these are great baby steps but they
don't go
far enough because
they make people jump through hoops they
have to come on the right days at the
right times
they might have to have extra food to
share
they want to read away their fines they
need to be literate
if we want people to use the library
again
we should just get rid of fines all
together
now you might think i've forgotten a
money piece where
we need to finance libraries right but
there's a couple of things to consider
when we think about
how fines function in library budgets
the first is that fines have never been
a stable
source of revenue they've always
fluctuated and in fact they've continued
to go down
over the last few decades when the
recession hit especially people's
ability to pay was hit as well
so for a lot of those 10 000 friends
that we've got at the library that
aren't able to use it
they might never be able to pay us when
we talk about eliminating their fines
we're not losing money
so much as the idea of money
and thirdly you might be surprised to
know
fines on average nationally are about
one and a half percent
of a library's operating budget now that
can still be a lot of money if you're
looking at a large library or a large
library system
the dollar amount can be high but it's
an achievable cut
for most libraries to absorb and finally
and maybe most importantly
fines cost us money to collect when you
start to factor in
all of the ways that we collect fines
supplies like mailers that we send out
to remind people of their fines services
like collections management services
even telephone and email notifications
can cost libraries money
and staff time is a huge cost for
libraries
so that our frontline staff is standing
there talking to people about their
fines
sometimes arguing with people about
fines
when we eliminate all of those pieces if
we got rid of fines we might actually
save money in our libraries
or at the very least we would be able to
reallocate our staff time to pursuits
that better fit those missions we talked
about
the other thing i want everybody to come
away understanding is that fines don't
actually work to do what we think they
do
the debate about fines whether we should
find how much we should find it isn't
new
we've been talking about it for almost
100 years
as long as that book was overdue
study after study has shown that the
reason library is fine is because of
strongly held beliefs
about the effectiveness of getting
materials back on time
backed by no evidence basically
we find because we've always find
so the best option for your libraries
is to put their mission first and they
will do that if their community members
ask it of them
when you leave here i hope you'll visit
your public library and talk to your
librarians
talk to your neighbors and community
members who serve on library boards
tell them that you know how important
literacy is
to everyone in your community that if
our libraries are truly for everyone
that they have to get rid of fines and
embrace their entire community
thank you
[Music]